ja
herzlich willkommen zu einem video heute
auch bekannt als der 25 dezember
interview mit dem über überall bekannten
kameramann frank kreft den man kann es
sind hier am feiern
wir feiern heute den ersten
weihnachtsfeiertag mit unserer family
wir fressen drei kilo kuchen hier
ich habe bisher zweieinhalb kilo äpfel
kuchen gegessen was ich tue gegessen
30-fachen von jochen zahn rasche
aufnahme auch unter die top acht
mexicana in dem was ich in meinem video
zeigen derzeit in seinen videos oder
zentral ich mache nämlich auch 1 1 wie
doc jetzt wir sind eben kein equipment
dabei youtube.com star sprach da wir
haben wir haben keine oder schlecht
leuchtet das bis zu 3 wir haben kein
equipment der weiße weihnachtsfeiertage
mit mit familie und so görg was hast du
so schön zu bekommen zu weihnachten der
apa ich habe zu weihnachten bekommen
eigentlich doch man habe socken bekommen
sollten
und ich hab noch bekommen kündigt das
doppel cash und cash natürlich
hauptsächlich kann eigentlich etwas
gemischt hauptsächlich kohle bekommen
jetzt einfach 50 euro insgesamt 150 euro
auf meinen verwandten bekommen aber nach
sieg denn alle einiger ein alko sales
alle also dass alle beim asx amanda
stevens 20 in einem dreier wären wir ja
die kommen
das wechselt tiefergelegt natürlich und
wir müssen jetzt auch gleich wieder
runter zu unseren verwandten york machen
das video relativ kurz schreibt mal
jetzt in die kommentare was ihr am
ersten weihnachtsfeiertag macht und auch
was ihr in den nächsten tagen noch so
vorhabt zweiter wenn das wetter 22
beispiel gibt es im dritten eine erneute
aber so bis neuer außerhalb die beatles
zu schauen die maxime herausfahren wir
haben übrigens gestern richtig richtig
geile gameplays aufgenommen und da ist
gar nicht erzählen was los war schon
gepostet maxa gepostet
falls ich schon gesehen habt gut bei
euch falls nicht erzählt es jetzt wenn
es dein gameplay aufgenommen wir hätten
einfach neuen diaz zu zweit surfer auf
hawaii auf halb zwei morgens nicht auf
84 und sich auch nicht auf wir auch
nicht von 44 euro heftig ja werden
glaube ich zwei an die eisen schwert
noch 2 1 engels vier diamanten später
das sind 4 1 2 3 4
und noch ein extra dir natürlich halle
gefegt dann glaube ich 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
runden straight gewonnen und ja die
gefäßwände nicht kommen wenn ich meine
übergab projekte mit krank macht und man
kommt jetzt schreibt alle her steckt
wann kommt die kommentare und damit
meine freude pur das video zu lang wird
wir müssen sie auch noch andere
einläutet macht's gut
haltet die ohren steif das nächste video
kommt wahrscheinlich mal jetzt ja da ist
und socken und peace out jetzt der papst